there's a lot to get into teddy
uh so much fun
finally the brandy bombshell has aired
ugh it is a lot we kind of hooked up
we hooked up and then who's we denise
and i
like kiss like everything it looked like
you guys were really struggling to
process what was happening can you walk
me through that moment
right in that moment while brandi is
telling us this this information
i started thinking oh my gosh this is
all on camera right now
like everything that she is saying is
out there once it's
out there and it's going to be on the
show it's on the show you know it's
there
no on twitter there was a lot of
speculation that it was a setup i saw
screen grabs that compared it to like
the vanderpump dog scene from last
season
what do you have to say to that i mean
if
if i knew if that was the situation that
was happening i probably would have
brushed my hair put on a little makeup
made an effort i think you if you
actually
watch while brandy saying it her hands
are shaking
she's a nervous wreck and like that's
why
i believe her because i was there in the
moment going
holy crap one this woman is telling me
the truth and two
she's hurt that's what sat with me
this was a completely different you know
side of her and i was like
i don't think she's you know right now i
think she's being honest
and the whole thing just made you up
like it
it really wasn't about their
you know what type of relationship that
they had it's that they have
a relationship that now that they're
sharing information with one another and
now
we have to hear about it when you went
over there did you know that brandy and
kim were going to drop by at all
i did not know for us it's like hey
be a kyle's at this time kyle teddy's
going to be here at this time that's the
way it's
set up for us so i mean yes it's set up
i don't just randomly pull into piles
but you know that's all we know well i
think
fans were a little confused because it
was like well randy's waiting out in the
car and then kim goes together and then
she's obviously like fully miked up but
there could have been a stop down there
where they're like randy let's toss a
mic on you and then go in like yeah i
mean there was a business
i mean any i don't know how it went down
because i was not there but i would
i do know that it wasn't like a quick
thing she didn't like sprint up the
stairs right after
so you know i have no idea well there's
also
then the like instagram detectives who
are trying to go back and piece together
they think you filmed that moment with
randy
after the rome trip had already happened
and you were back in l.a
oh no that's no definitely not i mean
here's the thing i can say about the
show they don't make up things
they're showing it in real time you kind
of touched on this with being in the
moment with brandy seeing her hand shake
but why do you take brandy's word over
denise's word
there's some things that become
completely evident
that it's impo even in that moment if i
was on the fence
now knowing what i know it would be
impossible for me to be on the fence
is there proof to what brandy is saying
beyond just her
word for it like are there screenshots
of texts and that sort of thing that
will be
revealed i mean it's real housewives
beverly hills what do you think
erica told me at the beginning of season
brandy has receipts
so yeah i mean but i i think
what everybody wants to focus on is you
know the
the alleged affair but that's not the
issue i mean truthfully the
issue is about what she was saying about
us
how erin was treating us it keeps
getting shifted to the other thing and
it's like that that isn't
that isn't our issue it's she's not
willing to really talk through
each issue because every time it's fine
she wants to control
every conversation and talk about what
she wants to talk about
which she only wants to keep bringing it
back to the kids because she knows in
that instance
the audience is always going to agree
with her on that of course nobody wants
their kids to hear that
but we also know that we're filming a
television show
it's like come on you bring up the
audience being on denise's side up until
this point the audience
has really been on denise's side what do
you and the group make of that so far
i think people see what they want to see
and
you know i i know how i feel and i can't
base
my life on what the audience is going to
think because
that's not real life you are the one who
winds up dropping the bomb on denise
in rome she has told us a lot of things
that are now out there about you guys
why don't you just say it she said you
two had sex
why was it necessary to bring up
the affair allegation there you're gonna
completely see why
once you watch the entire episode you
will understand why it gets to that
point
but i also need to be clear once
something is
already filmed it is out there so
you know denise posted something today
where like i can't believe teddy would
do
these you know salacious things about me
and say these things
why are you so mad at me i'm actually
not the one that said them
i repeated them after they had already
been said
on camera that's going to air on
television so why are we so upset at me
we can pretend that i'm a big shooter
all we want
but once it's out there it's out there
here's the thing
if brandy had a private conversation
with me about this and then i chose to
bring it into the group
yes call me sir because
that's what it would have been but it
was not a private conversation
it was film she doesn't like you at all
at all
she said horrible things about you
you're obnoxious you'll do anything
to be in this group because you've lived
under your doubt's shadow your whole
life
and you it's it was just like just mean
i give denise an opportunity to come
clean to me about the things she said
about me and then you'll just you'll
have to see what happens
okay you and denise are now in a little
bit of a social media back and forth
it seems just to give everybody
backstory
my dad always texts me after every
episode he thinks it's hilarious
he teases me and so my dad sent me a
joke
and he's saying uh i know you're busy in
my shadow butt and he sends me a picture
of
him and i and then like tries to do a
meme but it's like the worst meme ever
and he just says like dennis richards
never heard of him
and i like he's trying to make his
daughter feel better that's just been
like made fun of on national television
about something that she
has no control over and there's nothing
mean or salacious or anything about that
post
i wasn't coming at her i wasn't talking
about the brandy affair
i wasn't talking about anything like
that i simply was making a joke
with my father and for her to take it
upon herself to then post it as a main
post on her instagram
truly shows me who she is
and her goal is i want
anybody that follows me to try and go
after tenny
so it brings me back to the question why
is so mad at me
why is so upset with me i did this
didn't happen with me
i didn't bring this back into the group
i didn't become close friends with
brandy
and share all of these things i didn't
you did so why are we once again
becoming the victim here
when this was a choice that you made
so you think it's a deflection technique
of course but my joke between my dad and
i that i posted
had nothing to do with her relationship
with brandy
so the fact that she wants to post that
especially you know like if we're all
gonna
talk about our personal lives like she
knows what i'm going through right now
and
she's like you know what still i'm gonna
double down and i'm gonna really get her
i hope everyone attacks her today
like you know
you do you denise if that makes you feel
better you let that big narcissism show
you're denise
richard i am [ __ ] denise richards
kyle
do you see that people could also see
that you posting that text a text
exchange with your dad could also be
taken in like a similar way of like
you're going after her for no reason
well i'm not going after her for no
reason because she actually said things
about me and she ends up which you guys
will see
admitting to the fact i actually said
worse things about you teddy
but her putting it on there and saying
oh i can't believe teddy would stoop to
this level
well aren't you stooping to this level
you're posting it in order to get people
to come after me so
let's talk about the reunion because you
guys have shot it was it
good bad rena called it bullsh well i
mean i
something happened that was definitely
frustrating it's a crazy reunion it's a
completely different type of reunion
that i've ever
been a part of i mean cheers from
different people
highs lows the whole thing so i mean
those those of you viewers you're in for
a real treat it was a hot mess for us
did you guys get any clarity on the
situation or any resolution there
you're gonna have to wait and see did
you have any lingering questions at the
end of the reunion
yes yes okay well not really i kind of
already
feel in my heart what the answers are
okay you just didn't get
it from the person's mouth correct
okay and i think we know that person
overall did you prefer the virtual
reunion or would you have rather been in
person
you know in my mind going into it i mean
nobody really looks forward to the
reunion in general but i was like this
is going to be hard to do
and but really i think because we've
gotten so used to doing things on zoom
now
there really still was a great way to
connect you could
really see everybody so like i i think
that
it's still going to be an amazing
reunion i mean i i know
that there were moments like where my
girls in the back that like did my hair
and makeup they're like
you could like like audible like
have we seen the last of brandy this
season or will she come back
before the end i don't think that's the
end of friday
so we're going to see more of her i to
her
woke up the next morning she said erin
can never know this
don't kill me were you disappointed that
she was not there for
your part of the reunion she's gonna
film something separately with andy
you know for brandy's sake i think it's
hard if things are talked about you and
you're not able to be there
to you know defend yourself or to say
your point of view so i felt more
bad for brandy the person that's
involved in the drama should probably be
there so they can have their
you know day in court but right i think
the
fans are going to be disappointed to not
see denise and brandy
have a conversation well i mean you know
that
if brandy was there denise is not gonna
be showing up so that's what it
is do you think that's what happened
that
she threatened not to show up if brandy
came
i have no idea okay what is your hope
for this group moving forward it seems
like things are going to be tough
to repair with denise you know i think
that
i never know you never really know
because things shift
so much like remember even my first
season like erica and i butted heads
like we couldn't see i
i like i love erica now like we are
close
i trust her if i was arrested tomorrow
erica would be the person i called
you know like so your relationships
really do shift and people are like how
does that happen and it's because
if you both are really honest and you
both say like all right we're moving on
it's possible so i never say never when
it comes to this group
because we're a group of yes strong
loud-mouthed opinionated women
but we also have big hearts we also want
the best for each other
and you know i do think that you know
you can
you can change and you can change things
but you know you never know until you're
actually
in it i just realized if you've seen all
the episodes
then you know if the bravo bravo effing
bravo
moment actually airs and where it airs
bravo bravo
bravo i'm out i'm not doing this um are
you
trying to like do you think you have me
right now
i feel like this is a setup
but does it air andy said it's gonna air
i don't know if andy said it's gonna air
so i'm not answering this question
he said it's going to air when it makes
sense for it to air so i would assume
there's gonna be like a montage of
moments that somehow
add to an argument you're just gonna
have to keep watching